eu via que a emissão e vou cumpri-la o
texto de um ponteiro
e agora como é que eu tiro rápido aqui o
meu deus eu ainda estou lhe olhar a
explicar que eu quero que o gil é aquela
manhã diário rádio caraças televisión o
retrato de warhol
arigatô na luta bateu com violência é
muito bom quando do conemi mancha e
pastel de frango pais bastei de fila
angu pato com laranja no chão que quilón
que e dom
nunca vi o euro ou o dólar
a festa que hoje tem 10 grosso é ayew
minha vida tanto um bom vôo chega casulo
travar eo batom na minha mulher era só
um a um do que a procura do nosso gesto
é também diretor aqui o pescoço e também
podem deitar as vaias que o ântero
batista bombo e fiquei com as vaias fora
não é toda hora é este meu gesto eu
cheirava pai do meu pai a a água lá
praquele cowboy na ponte rasa procurei
corajosa é já que não até mas vou
debater o corinthinha pode ser mais
conhecida eo laser é já visto na boca do
sul
[Música]
nenhum partido
este medo nem dinheiro a este mesmo
homem
eu sou o diabo o capeta só demônio só
tratará
vocês mostram reúnem boca cool
[Música]
nós vamos apresentar um canal de um
amigo meu que é um elo aí eu faz vídeos
de dor e fala demônios e de tudo o que
bizarro na internet por isso passei por
lá eu vou deixar o link é que fez um
contínuo do dew e plano em todos os
vídeos com este boy ecko é que é
e agora eu vou comer umas meninas não
gostou
[Música]